What are your thoughts on corned stem cell treatment in addition to our program?
So stem cell treatment. We're not talking about stem cell transplants. So stem cell
transplant would be a treatment for leukemias. That's totally different. So corned stem cell
treatment that can be either injectables or it can be IV can be very beneficial for different things.
So I had several doctor friends that were doing stem cell injections for degenerative
these degenerative hips with great success. The problem with it wasn't you typically had to redo
it. It wasn't long-term success but I know they're doing corned stem cell IVs and injections
for all sorts of different things. Now I do know that there it's not as big anymore but it was
big about eight years ago when stem cells first came out they thought there was going to be
the treatment and the cure for everything like so many different things. And it was used in some
alternative cancer clinics. Now I had a big problem with that. In fact I read a book of a
practitioner who wrote a book on stem cells and he was considered kind of an authoritarian on
stem cells at the time because he was kind of at the cutting edge of it and he was doing it in his
clinic and for cancer patients they did not see the success with it that they thought they were
going to see and I don't know if they are actually continuing to do that procedure for cancer. Now
the struggle with it with cancer is that stem cells by definition can be pluricoted which means they
can turn into different tissues. So whatever the body needs to do with those stem cells it can make
different cells. The struggle with a person with cancer using stem cells is that it can turn into
and stimulate cancer growth. So that was the fear in most practitioners use of stem cells for cancer.
That's why most practitioners did not do stem cells with cancer. I had one patient years ago that
was from Canada that did that went to Colorado to get stem cells for her cancer and she passed away.
Now I'm not saying it was from the stem cells but her cancer did go crazy and she died. I don't
know what it was from. So I've never been a fan of corded stem cells for cancer. Now if you don't
have cancer you're using corded stem cells for other things like early dementia or Parkinson's and
things. By all means I don't think there's a harm to it. So if you don't have a cancer diagnosis I
don't think that there's a real harm to using stem cell therapy. I don't know if there's a
practitioner that's doing it for dementia or Parkinson's or something like that with great success
then by all means it's something to think about. The other therapy for dementia or Parkinson's
that I would consider highly would be hyperbaric chambers but you would want to, before you
purchase a hyperbaric chamber you would want to find a clinic that has a hyperbaric chamber and
see if you can go in it safely. I personally with my sinus issues I can't use a hyperbaric chamber.
Some people get claustrophobic and some people they just can't do it so it's something to think about.
But corded stem cells for non-cancer conditions can be extremely beneficial. Like I said I had
practitioner friends that used them for injectables as for knee issues, severe degeneration and knees,
severe degeneration and hips. It's a pretty good success rate. It's a couple of my good friends that
were very honest with me you know they said they saw 60 to 70% success rate with it. However they
did say that typically in a year so they had to do it again but still if you want to prevent to show
knee surgery and the replacement or hip replacement I'd go down that route before I'd go with
replacement surgery so I think it's a good choice.